from hibernation to high energy team
Biden is once again trying to reassure
Americans that our sleepy Commander in
Chief has got the stamina to be the most
powerful person on the planet President
Biden finally emerging in Allentown
Pennsylvania today after taking it easy
with no public appearances since Monday
according to a new report by NBC it's
all part of the White House's plan to
make Joe look more youthful and ramp up
quote more informal remarks unannounced
stops at diners and appearances in
social media posts and podcast but boy
did that backfire today the president
looking totally lost as he shuffled
around various
businesses on shirt
you this is Morgan Sherwin and
Sam
Umi there are our team members here the
White House is also rolling out a doctor
Joe Biden that is she's trying to
convince Americans that Joe is the
Energizer
Bunny I think what people don't see is
how hard Joe works every single day that
he gets up thinking what he can do for
the American people and he does that you
know it his job doesn't end when we just
have dinner together at 7:00 I see that
strength and that resilience and that
steadiness every single day I say his
age is an
asset he's wise yes and he's wise he has
wisdom he has experience he knows every
leader on the world stage he's lived
history he knows history and Nancy
Pelosi is also trying to puff up the
81-year-old president president
president has a the weight of the world
on his shoulders he's the president of
the United States a very challenging job
they're only so many hours in the day
you can tell them everything you've done
but nobody gets elected because they
deserve it they get elected because of
what they're going to do next and what
he is going to do next is again to
continue the work he's done for
America's Working Families and many
people are appreciating and enjoying it
they just are not giving him credit for
it all right Jesse Nancy Pelosi says
that many people are appreciating and
enjoying the work of the presidency but
they're just not giving him the credit
do you agree well the polls disagree
andan he's in the dumpster and many
presidents have governed to end campaign
during Wars pandemics depressions Joe
Biden's just like any other president we
expect him to be able to walk and Cheo
gum at the same time
if I were the White House I'd just maybe
have him go play a round of golf if you
can't golf judge have him play corn hole
he didn't even flip the coin at the Army
Navy game this fall he had Lloyd Austin
do it for him these are just simple
things Dana said yesterday just hold a
cabinet meeting spray the room so it
looks like you're in charge in managing
something take a picture of him watching
Sunday Night Football at 8:30 on a
Sunday it's not that hard but they keep
giving us images of him struggling with
the beach chair nodding off at a meeting
those things just don't Inspire the
American people and then they tell us
that no one can keep up with them and
now we feel like we're being lied to I
don't think he's gonna I think he might
actually write off Arizona because it's
too far of a flight out there I do and
you he always says the same line
remember don't compare me to the
almighty compare me to the alternative
if you compare him the alternative
Donald Trump was up at midnight working
they said it was he was on cocaine
and and then he comes out at 11:00 in
the morning and they say oh he has
executive time in the morning Joe
doesn't even show up for 3 days straight
and they don't say a thing what they're
going to do is they're going to try to
bring him across the finish line and
probably the first or second year he's
going to hand the keys to the White
House to kamla and then we're stuck with
her all right Harold Joe Biden claims
that Joe is an asset but in a recent M
poll 76% of Americans think the guy is
too old to serve another term as
president who's out of touch Jill or the
American people good to be with you I
think that I think that uh it's not a
surprise that Joe Biden and Nancy Pelosi
are out campaigning uh for for Joe Biden
I see members of the Senate on the
Republican side and members of Congress
and former cabinet members for president
Trump out campaigning for him as they
are for other candidates I think your
larger point is um are they responding
to Something in the polling data uh to
to Dana's point and to to Jesse's Point
are they trying to to rebut or are they
trying to count our notion that the
president doesn't have their energy to
be president for another four years um
that's probably something that's showing
showing up in in their polling data uh
if I were him I I'd be doing exactly
what he's doing I I don't think those
pictures I think the pictures were
unfair to him today there have been
pictures in video before where he has
not aren't they real they are but I
think your characterization of them I
disagree with him falling down the
stairs and up the stairs airplane that's
a problem it's a challenge but today I
saw a president trying to engage with
voters trying to engage with people and
ultimately this race will come down and
what presidential races come down to is
the economy in a better spot today uh in
6 months from now 7 months from now
eight months from now that will help him
uh are we able to respond like he was
able to respond to De Administration and
responding to the houthis without
thought a blistering attack it was
overdue long overdue and I'm glad they
did it we will be challenged in in the
coming months around that and we'll see
how the president responds and three
there's no doubt presidential contest
are contrast and if president Trump whom
I believe will lock this nomination up
in the next month or so because because
of the the early nature of some of these
primaries and caucuses we will be in
store for the longest general election
uh that we that we've ever had in this
country with President Trump and
President Biden who are well known by
the voters it will be very interesting
to see how the two of them try to
differentiate themselves and demonstrate
to the country that one of them is best
to lead us for the next four years well
Dana two questions number one do you
agree with Harold but number two Harold
is giving the president kudos for
responding to the houthi attacks hoodie
attacks and the truth is I think they
hit 120 times or some crazy number uh
and he wasn't even in touch with his
General Lloyd auson the fourstar general
is a DEX SE SE def yeah yeah that was
that's been the tongue twister for you
all week SE the secde is what they call
him um they they didn't speak last week
but they did speak uh last night
apparently and Lloyd Austin's working
from his hospital bed that's a new thing
from instead of work from home you can
work from the hospital but glad he's
feeling better I think that the strikes
were strategic and targeted and smart I
had the dod spokesperson on today and
she said it was a proactive strike and I
said you want to revise that because to
this was reactive after we had been hit
so many times and the shipping lanes had
gotten so screwed up that now you're
going to see more inflation because some
of those container ships are up 600% in
cost because they have to go all the way
around now I do think that the best
asset that Joe Biden has in Pennsylvania
is not Jill Biden the first lady
everyone expects her to say nice things
about her husband and she's going to be
out there trying to do that but it is
Governor Josh Shapiro this is a guy who
is a bright star for the Democratic
party he's not trying to run for
president yet he was able to do
something this week that helped Biden
and Biden might not have even realized
it Biden was going to change William
Penn Park to some sort of what was it
they're going back to the Native
American and in one day Josh Shapiro
said actually no the name of our state
is Pennsylvania and we're not going to
change it and Biden back down so if you
look at the polls recently just I think
yesterday Biden is up to on Trump and
Pennsylvania where he he had been behind
Pennsylvania is going to be very
important if the Democrats hope to hold
on it will be there I also wanted to say
one thing about Nancy Pelosi she says
the weight of the world is on Joe
Biden's shoulders that is true for any
president but for Joe Biden when you
think about that you feel sorry for him
because the weight of the world is on
his shoulders rather than thank God the
weight of the world is on his shoulders
whoever it's going you there's just a
difference and I don't think that
trotting her out to say things like Joe
Biden is so energetic is going to work
all right Greg so the president is in
Allentown Pennsylvania today and uh 36%
of Americans approve of his economic
policies does any of this making sense
to the American people I don't know I
don't know when I see Dr Jill I don't
see a first lady I see a visitor
Visiting Angel and I was thinking about
this topic and it reminded me of why the
Trump town hall on Fox a few days ago
was so helpful because it's a reminder
of what's necessary for the job you know
love or hate Trump at least he's present
you know that's not a lot to ask for but
in this day and age it is he shows up
he's in his suit he's ready to go it's
like what Dana said he goes to
interviews town halls and he goes to
court all in the same damn day he shows
up he's the last to leave not the first
to go compare this to the invalid in
Chief right Trump completes a work day
and we're just happy when Joe completes
a sentence so I go back to my original
thesis from years ago about uh Trump you
don't have to like him to vote for him
he's not your Bridge partner you're not
going on a cruise with him this isn't
the golden
Bachelor he's a typical hard charging
executive he can be an a-hole but you
rely on him for what he does not for
what he says or even how he is some of
the best people that I worked for uh or
hired they weren't congenial they
weren't polite they were brisk they were
impatient they were arrogant bosses but
I knew at the end of the day that you
know the stuff got done I had a lot of
nice bosses that drove companies into
the ground I know I mean I I won't get
into it but you can look it up um and
again if I want a lawyer or an agent to
represent me I don't want a guy who
makes the other side feel good I want
the other side to be uncomfortable even
worried perhaps scared problem with Joe
is we're scared with Trump they're
scared the grifting globalists the
corrupt career politicians the tinpot
fascist countries nipping at our heels
if we have issues with Trump imagine how
they must feel well said thank you Greg
it's Friday all right and Dana's with us
on Friday yes yes ahead one of the
biggest car rental companies hitting
Biden right where it hurts over his
Dopey EV Obsession hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else